an upstate new york county library has
just hosted
four events the events were for 11 to 18
year olds and the events were to quote
learn the art of drag from a local drag
queen
we went from
drag queens reading the kit reading
unrelated books non-sexual books to
little kids
to
teaching little kids how to twerk and
jiggle and strut and put put on sexual
performances in cross-sex clothing
in about four four or five years
that's how quickly that happened what is
drag drag is when you put on
a caricature a hyper-sexualized version
of women's clothing when you are a man
and you dance around in a very sexually
provocative way that's what drag is it
is intrinsically sexual and obscene
and
grown pervert men are now going to the
library on a taxpayer dime to teach 11
year olds how to do that
presumably for their own sexual pleasure
and gratification
and the pleasure and gratification of
the weirdo adults who attend these shows
it took like five years
forget about drag queen story hour for a
second
we went from
[Music]
pretty much no one even talking about
transgenderism in 2012 was
transgenderism an issue in 2012 i don't
really remember it being one
to
11 year olds putting on drag queens sex
sexual performance shows
in 10 years forget about that forget
about the transvestitism at all for a
second
in 2011 barack obama and hillary clinton
said marriage is a sacred union between
a man and a woman and gay marriage or
same-sex marriage is completely
unthinkable
to
transiting the kids and putting on
sexualized drag shows performed by 11
year olds within
11 years
11 years obergefell was in 2015 that was
seven years ago this happened
really really fast the slippery slope
slipped faster
even then the most alarmist
conservatives would have predicted a
decade ago
and it's not even just the kids learning
how to do the little dances for the
pervert adults in the auditorium
the kids are now learning
that they can they can make money by
putting on those shows there was a quote
family-friendly drag show in palm
springs california that taught the
little kids how to make money by
jiggling and shimmying around in
stiletto heels and provocative clothing
we've blurred the kids faces out
obviously
this uh this
video coming from libs of tick tock
there you got the little kids putting on
the drag show with some
gigantic pervert man in a thong
dancing and strutting around him
and then the adults are throwing dollar
bills at the kit
and the man is sticking his derriere
[Applause]
out i can't tell is that a man or a
woman
can't tell don't know don't really want
to know
look at all those adults clapping like
seals
[Music]
look at all that money you just made
good job strut around
[Applause]
oh there's a different drag queen saying
look
don't don't forget all that money pick
up that money like a prostitute pick it
up like a stripper off the ground that's
right little tiny child that's right and
maybe you come back up here if you want
to make a little bit more money maybe
you can jiggle for these pervert adults
a little bit more huh
it makes it even worse the money part
makes it even worse
it's
i i'm going to be a communist by the end
by the end of this social revolution i'm
going to because
if this is capitalism if if capitalism
taken to its extreme degree
is paying little kids to put on sex
shows for perverts in palm springs then
let's knock it down workers of the world
unite soak the rich take the money let's
whatever it is
this is so
so
wrong and creepy
and it's it actually is a little bit of
a capitalist problem it actually is a
little bit of a free market problem i
mean all of the people pushing this are
far left wingers and commies and pinkos
and weirdos but but the people who let
this happen
often did so in the name of free markets
and the free marketplace of ideas and
capitalism
so often you heard people say listen
look we have the public library this is
a free neutral space where we can say
whatever we want we have viewpoint
neutrality and it's absolutely fine very
few people are going to show up to drag
queen story hour events but if they want
to that's totally fine listen i i'm
pretty sure if companies get woke
they're going to go broke but
you know they we can never interfere in
the marketplace to say that this is not
allowed we can absolutely not no
regulation whatsoever we can't have
governments regulating drag queens and
performances oh that's big government we
got to get big government out of our
life no i
if
if
stopping little kids from putting on
sexual performances for perverts if that
is big government then call me joseph
freaking stalin man because i want
government big enough to at least do
that but of course this was always a
psyop this was always a
ridiculous
slogan that the conservatives adopted
within the last 10 or 20 years because
conservatives are not for small
government
conservatives are not opposed to big
government
conservatives are for
limited government
and we are against unlimited government
we're against totally arbitrary
government or against tyranny or against
the capricious use of power
but those are different things limited
does not necessarily mean small we have
a country of 330 million people and we
govern a global empire whether we want
to admit it or not you cannot have
small government in that kind of a
system it's not possible it has not
existed for well over 100 you're
probably 150 years
if that by the way the the founding
fathers that conservatives tend to like
the most george washington john adams
alexander hamilton those were not small
government conservatives they wanted a
more energetic government they just
wanted it to be within certain limits
and absolutely if
protecting kids from being paid little
dollar bills by perverts to put on weird
sex shows for these adults in palm
springs if that does not fall within the
just limits of government then nothing
does then there is then there is no
government then we're living in
anarcho-tyranny which increasingly is
what our government looks like it's so
pathetic this this is a somehow an even
sadder story on the same topic
there's a girl there's a 17 year old
girl who was a cheerleader camp and she
got choked out by a 25 year old dude who
dressed up like a woman and pretended
that he was a woman and was at this
cheerleader camp why was a 25 year old
dude
forget even a transvestite 25 year old
dude why was any 25 year old
at a cheerleader camp with a 17 year old
i don't know couldn't possibly tell you
because we live in a weird culture but
the 25 year old dude who dressed up like
a chick was at this cheer camp and the
17 year old girl pointed out that he was
a dude
allegedly and then the 25 year old dude
choked out this little girl
this
underage teenage girl
and now
fortunately the 25 year old dude got
booted out of the camp he never should
have been allowed in it in the first
place
but now the father of the of the girl is
speaking out and how is he speaking out
he's he's fighting back against claims
that his daughter is transphobic i kid
you not i kid you not he says my
daughter
is 100 supportive of the trans community
i have a gay son so don't tell me i'm
effing homophobic we're not we're we're
very pro-trans we just we just don't
want the transgender 25 year old dudes
at the little girls cheer camp to choke
out all the little girls please this is
so sad this is where we're at now hey
hey hey i want to make one thing totally
clear after my daughter was my teenage
daughter was just victimized by this
hulking pervert who should be locked
away in a mental asylum i just want to
make one thing clear we're very
pro-trans
what
why
why are you pro-trans
you say you use this word transphobic
transphobia doesn't mean
anything
transphobia literally would mean the
irrational fear of
transgenderism and it doesn't mean
anything because people who are critical
of transgenderism are not irrational
it's totally rational
transgenderism is irrational criticizing
transgenderism is totally rational and
it's not a fear we're just critical of
it we just say it's a mistake in
anthropology and we reject it
so inasmuch as that's what transphobia
means everyone should be very very
transphobic
everyone should be very critical of
transgenderism and reject the this
mistake in anthropology entirely and
transphobia as the libs use that term
should be encouraged it should be
normalized and it should be enshrined in
the law
and if even the conservatives or if even
the people who are victimized who are
most clearly victimized by
transgenderism are using this same kind
of language and saying no no please
don't call me anti-trans we are totally
sunk folks head on over to ahs.gov
knowles now more than ever it is very
important to keep your budget in check
you can do that with american home
shield they offer a great choice of
three plans to help cover the cost to
repair or replace parts of your major
home systems and appliances both new and
old we're talking hvac systems plumbing
kitchen appliances their plans help
protect parts of up to 23 essential home
systems and appliances electronics
coverage is available for an unlimited
number of eligible items such as
smart watches flat screen tvs and more
other options include roof leak repair
and pool and spa coverage coverage is
available no matter how old your systems
and appliances are plus they're offering
an exclusive 50 off for our listeners i
love it i absolutely you need to do the
responsible thing protect your wallet
protect your home and your appliances
keep your home up and running and your
budget on track with american home
shield right now our listeners can take
50 off their most comprehensive plans
that is at
ahs.com
knowles to save 50 bucks ahs.com
knowles 50 bucks off any plan american
home shield be sure with the shield
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply see plan for details
did you like that clip i certainly did
thank you so much for helping us to
reach 1 million youtube subscribers
that's huge now next goal one billion
that's right ring the bell subscribe get
the notifications we will see you
at a billion
[Music]
you